der russische präsident wladimir putin
hat am mittwoch in moskau bereits seine
15 jahres ansprache vor dem parlament
gehalten dabei warnte er vor der
stationierung von nuklear
mittelstreckenraketen in europa sollte
dies geschehen werde russland nicht nur
die länder ins visier nehmen in denen
solche waffen aufgestellt werden sondern
auch die usa selbst sagte putin
die usa sollten daher die risiken genau
abwägen bevor sie irgendwelche schritte
unternehmen
die usa und die nato werfen russland vor
dass die neuen raketen eine reichweite
von über 500 kilometern haben und damit
nach dem eu vertrag verboten sind sowohl
die usa als auch russland haben das
bilaterale abkommen inzwischen gekündigt
das damit nach weiteren sechs monaten
ausläuft der enev vertrag gilt als
grundstein der atomaren abrüstung in den
80er jahren inzwischen besitzen aber
auch andere länder wie china diesen
waffentyp ohne an ein rüstungskontroll
abkommen gebunden zu sein
[Applaus]